if you're having a bad day there are
three simple things that I use to help
turn it around hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today was a bad day it
did not start well for me I woke up
earlier than i wanted to after a bad
night's sleep I got to the office and
was excited to get on the phone with my
agent we're talking about a book deal
and they hated my new proposal and
thought the first version was a lot
better so I'm now back to the drawing
board and then I got on the phone with
my media coach and she's telling me that
I need to be tougher give more tough
love and ripping into me on the recent
videos and radio shows that i've been
doing and it's all great you know
they're right there's nothing wrong with
the advice or giving they're helping me
it was just hard to hear and sometimes
people beat up on you and it just brings
you down and then I'm taking off to
leave and it's raining about my best
friend to work anyway it was a bad
morning like I got to do something I got
to get out of this funk because I got a
lot of stuff to do today and so there's
three things that I do whenever I'm you
know start the bad start the day off
poorly the first one is try to do
something active so try to get out of
your office go do something active go do
something to help you have fun I went to
a Zumba class so twelve o'clock i got up
went to a Zumba class and zoom was kind
of like latin line dancing so you havin
a lot of fire in your day and saying
you're getting the sweat going and you
release all all the crap at least for me
all the crap that i was thinking about
is gone i'm just having fun in the class
so first get some exercise second has
helped somebody I find when I help
somebody I feel better I feel better
about myself and feel better about what
I'm doing helps put my problems in
perspective and if you want to live a
happier life at least in my opinion you
got to help people and so what ideas I'd
brought my father to the Zumba class
with me and this is his first zumba
class ever and it was fun watching him
who's getting the moves he's having fun
is getting his heart beating he's
breaking a sweat and it was a fun thing
to be able to do together and the third
thing if that fails if the exercise
doesn't help do something to help
somebody doesn't help I rely on sugar
and caffeine so I went to my Tim Hortons
across the street and picked up a nice I
cappuccino hmm so one of those things
you just helps me or all three of them
together usually gets me back into a
better mood because I got a lot of stuff
to do today I got to record 14 videos
for you guys I have to work on some
deals I have to get back to a lot of
people on email there's a lot that I
have to do today and I don't want to be
in a bad mood now if all that fails if
you're still in a bad mood after you
tried all that then just let the bad
mood stay for the day and wake up
tomorrow and do something to grow your
business and be happier because often
when you sleep on it it gets better but
if you can at least for me I try to get
rid of those the bad moods and help me
focus on what I'm supposed to be doing
at work so again quick recap you're in a
bad mood break out of your slump one get
some exercise I'm with a Zumba class to
do something to help somebody I brought
my father along and three if that all
fails sugar and caffeine will get you
through thanks for watching everybody
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up below I love seeing those come
in and hey I want to hear from you
please leave a comment below about this
video or if you have a question for your
own company I'd love to help answer it I
always read those comments I love soon
come in thank you and I'll see you soon